Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman. I've been sitting in
for David all of this week. He will return to you
on Monday. I promise he has given me his word,
but. Let's finish things up here, shall we?
And of course, as I've done every day this week,
you got to talk a little bit about Joe Manchin,
Public Enemy number one. And now we're finding
out that Republicans, including Senate Minority
Leader Mitch McConnell, are actively trying
to recruit Joe Manchin over to the dark side.
Come to us officially. They're telling him. And
that's not hyperbole, either, literally. It's
been reported that John Cornyn admitted to sending
Joe Manchin a text message, inviting him to come
and join the Republican Party in the Senate.
Where are your friends? You're just like us.
Come on, Joe. What do you say? Mitch McConnell,
however, said in an interview with The New York
Times. Obviously, we would love to have him on our
team. I think he'd be more comfortable. Why in the
world would they? The Democrats want to call him
a liar and try to hotbox him and embarrass him.
I think the message is we don't want you
around. Obviously, that is up to Joe Manchin,
but he is clearly not welcome on that side of
the aisle. Joe Manchin himself this week also
talked about the the bullying that he is
receiving from those on the left for killing
the build back better act and said, you know,
they ought to push me into the Republican Party.
That's what he said. And I think these Republicans
took that as if they're not going to push you.
We're going to try to pull you. So come on,
Joe. And to be honest, think about it this
way. Obviously, if Joe Manchin were to leave the
Democratic Party, go over to the Republicans,
they get the majority, they take over the
committees and all of that. It's horrible, right?
Unidentified: Right. Is it?
Speaker 1: The Democrats are
already struggling to get anything done because
they have only 50 and Republicans have 50.
And Joe Manchin is the biggest
roadblock now I understand 100
percent if Joe Manchin were to leave, the
Democrats become a Republican, give them the
majority. Nothing gets done. You know, the Voting
Rights Act? Kiss that goodbye. Any chance of
getting a different version of build back better
gone. But what are the chances of those things
happening with Joe Manchin as a Democrat anyway?
Wouldn't it make more sense electorally speaking?
For the Democrats to boot, Joe Manchin, don't
give him the option. Tell him you're out.
And then let the Republicans take the fall for
it. The public wants the build back better act.
So if you can pin the whole thing on Republicans,
if Joe Manchin were to go over there.
Wouldn't that be a better campaign message? You
know, look, we tried to give you all these things,
and it got so bad that one of our guys ended up
becoming a Republican because he hates it so much.
He doesn't want you to have good things. So he's
joining the party that continuously refuses to
let you have good things because that's what
they stand for, because that's who they are.
So if you want these things, we
got to get the majority back.
Now, as again, I've talked about that this
week, Republicans have to defend 20 seats.
20 seats in 20, 22. That requires a lot of
money. And the odds significantly reduced
that you're going to hold on to every single
one of those seats, the more you have to defend.
You also have members who are considering
retirement, some who've already announced
retirement. So in those new races, of course,
that's going to be far more expensive,
and it opens the door for a Democrat
challenger to seize the seat. So.
Democrats could probably come
up with a winning message
by getting rid of Joe Manchin because again, then
the entire boogeyman becomes the Republican Party.
I'm just throwing it out there as a possibility,
as a very real electoral strategy that the
Democratic Party should at least consider. And
if you're not willing to kick Joe Manchin out,
we're not willing to push him over to the
other side. Then at the very least, don't
let him get his hands on the DNC money when he's
not going to support the Democratic Party itself.
I mean, after all, reports have also come out
this week saying that he is receiving so much
corporate cash right before he announced that
he was not going to be supporting the build back
better act. So Joe Manchin will be fine. Hell,
he's not even up for reelection for a while.
So don't worry about him. Kick him out. Make him
part of the enemy. And see what you can come up
with in terms of electoral strategy messaging,
once that happens. You keep them in the party.
You're going to have to deal with him and his
problems and the negativity that he brings with
him for at least another full year. And to me
personally, I just don't think that's worth it.